also new tonight at 11 Nevada's attorney
general says the Clark County School
Board violated the state's open meeting
law in 2021 discussing the future of
superintendent Dr Jesus Jara that
meeting in question took place February
3rd of 2021 where the board discussed
giving Dr Jara notice that his contract
wouldn't be automatically renewed but to
look back at it A.G Ford says the board
failed to give the public enough notice
when they moved that meeting from 8 in
the morning to 4 P.M the board later
fired Dr Jara that October only to
change their minds less than a month
later current School Board trustees will
discuss the AG's remarks at their next
board meeting